An IDS can be deployed at
the perimeter of a network, or
subnet, to monitor traffic going in and
out of the network.
Such an IDS is a network IDS.
It typically uses
a packet capturing tool,
such as the libpcap tool to
obtain network traffic data.
The packet data contains the complete
information about network connections.
For example, if a user connects to
a website using his browser, the packet
data will contain all the TCP handshake
information between the browser and
the web server, and all the URL
requests from the browser and
the return page contents
from the server.
That is, by examining the packet data,
the IDS has all the data sent and
received by the user's browser.
If the user's machine is infected by
a bot malware, for example, any attempts
to connect to a website for command and
control, the network IDS will be able
to see that the traffic looks like
CNC activities and output an alert.